[Musique]
c'est l'histoire d'une équipe de water
polo gay comme on surnomme les crevettes
pas été une histoire de tolérance et
d'amitié est réalisé par cédric le galop
et maxime gauvard c'est ici
l'association homosexuelle pour
l'intégration la tolérance et le respect
dans le water-polo ensemble hi mom de
penne je ne sais pas maintenant
enfin c'est l'histoire d'un film au
casting le plus déjanté de l'année
félix david romain alban cédric merci
d'être là on parle des crevettes pas été
cédric vous réaliser ce film avec maxime
chauvary un spécial du jury au festival
du film de comédie de l'alpe d'huez une
standing-ovation et quelques jours à
paris pour l'avant première parisienne
alors juste un mot déjà les crevettes
pailleté sa part d'une de vos
expériences personnelles
racontez nous un petit peu ouais une de
mes expériences mais qui en fait mon
quotidien depuis huit ans je fais partie
d'une équipe de water-polo gay qui a
changé ma vie et qui a inspiré ce film
parce qu'ils sont très inspirant en fait
c'est une équipe de dans laquelle il ya
beaucoup de bienveillance beaucoup
d'amour où on a le droit d'être qui on
veut c'est pour ça que ça a changé ma
vie et ça a changé la vie de tous ceux
qui sont dans le groupe
c'est ce qu'on voit dans le film on a le
droit d'être haut en couleurs on a le
droit d'être extravagant on a le droit
de faire un peu ce qu'on veut dans un
cadre extrêmement bienveillant avec des
personnalités très différentes et donc
c'est forcément très inspirant pour un
film
quel est votre regard à tous pour vos
personnages dites-nous chacun un petit
mot sur votre personnage
bah moi c'est au bruit sur le nouvel
arrivant dans l'équipe c'est un peu un
peu le candide quoi la personne un peu
candide qui découvre la vie et qui est
qui ouais qui apprend l'apprécient en
fait qui apprend la légèreté tout ça
s'est fait assez chouette ça c'est le
cac prend à s'assumer
oui qui apprend s'assumer le meilleur
mais je le trouve un peu touchant parce
qu'il est il a pour des raisons qui sont
autres que cette équipe et du coup on
accompagne par son regard mais on est
des raisons plutôt sentimental et du
coup on accompagne par son regard et on
vient avec lui et cette traversée a
essayé de savoir comment va pouvoir se
reconstruire des seniors moi mon
histoire c'est que j'ai changé de sexe
j'ai transitionner et elle arrive elle
est radieuse
rien ne l'arrête et là les obsédés par
la chorégraphie
elle chante elle rassemble les gens
c'est beau et même sera le tournage
d'ailleurs j'étais la seule personne
avec des missions et alban et plein
d'autres venaient toujours crispé amène
ici c'est beau c'est un boom allemand
que vous dire sur jambes agent cece
c'est le personnage qui a créé l'équipe
des crevettes pailleté qui a qui a réuni
tout ce beau monde que vous ouvrir
d'autres ccc plus mystérieux voilà dans
le film
[Musique]
comment on fait pour ne pas tomber dans
la caricature en fait le meilleur moyen
pour combattre la caricature c'est de la
jouer à fond
c'est exactement ça parce que déjà nous
dans nos vies c'est ce qu'on fait on
n'est pas dupe on les connaît les
clichés son homosexualité mais on se les
réapproprie pour s'en moquer nous-mêmes
pour mieux les détourner
c'est quelque chose qui est très propre
à la communauté gay et encore plus à
cette bande de potes où on surjoue qui
on est bon on va se quitter avec le
chant et la corée des crevettes pas été
quand même non allez on n'est pas venu
les mains vides
on a un cadeau pour vous à la halle à
regarder cette beauté alors là rien à
dire plus plaisir brodeur parce que je
vous conseille c'est de ne pas la
laisser entrer dans un coin parce qu'on
s'est beaucoup février 17 vs maintenant
mais il est hors de question je la
quitte plus buck
mais du coup vous allez faire la
chorégraphie avec nous bien sûr on va
vous des corps ok on est crevé pas été
touché
[Rires]